your hair's dry you had the look an hour
ago
of guy who was running late got out of
the shower got dressed and ran out the
door because you had kind of that wet
hair like i didn't have time to really
do anything today and i just
off i go okay one no i i was sitting
here in this seat
20 minutes before air time two uh i went
to sleep at 1 30 in the morning because
the cubs were pitching a no hitter a
team no hitter
that's dedication three
i don't know what three is i lost three
because i was up so late
all right that works uh let's answer
some questions from the pft
mailbag on our final edition before our
involuntary summer break at j train 33
between you two who wants aaron rodgers
to be the happiest
and have his best year there's no
question it's you that's you've been
expressing genuine concern for the
mental health and overall
physical well-being of aaron rodgers for
weeks now
he he is a cry for help he he feels
mistreated
and uh you can't you can't have that you
know in today's world
if your boss is mistreating you you got
to get out so aaron rodgers
you got to get out man life's too short
life's too short to be
miserable at your workplace and you're
miserable at your workplace right now
so i care deeply about aaron rodgers
uh and his well-being and his his
happiness and his mental state so
i really just want to see him have live
laugh and love you know what i mean
dance like no one's watching that kind
of stuff
all kidding aside i really do think he
is going to play this year uh wait i
wasn't
kidding i was not kidding i was knocking
i know i know
i know i know i was not kidding i wanted
him to be happy although i
although listen i i do think it's a
better story as i said earlier
for all of us who cover the nfl if he is
there
there there there is so much potential
ammunition
for dysfunction if he's there if he if
he's not what's there to talk about
you know jordan love and they're not
going to be very good maybe the bears
are a great value at plus 350 to win
the division but if if he's there it's
it's it's got the potential to be very
very compelling
wire to wire um and i think he will be
there i
i watched matt leflore's final ota press
conference
last saturday i think it was and there
was something he said there that made me
think he knows that rogers is going to
be there talking about
camp arms blake bortles jake dolagala
the idea that
you know once we have as we get closer
to camp
more clarity we'll probably be making
some moves i think he knows that aaron's
going to be there so they're not going
to need those those camp
arms that they currently have to
distribute all the reps during
individual drills
i need this to end now for your mental
state for your mental happiness mike
florio because
i enjoy it hey spend an entire thursday
going through
the coveted rules and a saturday
watching matt lafleur's
uh press conference so it was 10. 10
minutes
we need you to have the happiness that
you seek in life so aaron rodgers make a
decision so florio
can stop obsessing about you it was 10
minutes of a saturday morning it was
background noises i otherwise was
was uh reading more documents to put
some more
pins together like charlie from always
sunny in philadelphia all right
uh at n9527
narendra i don't understand the first
part of it what is a big cat
top 10 quarterback in the nfl i prefer
the second half which quarterback
does he want to be bears quarterback
from the quarterbacks who played at
wisconsin university
uh have there been well i guess it would
be russell well it's russell wilson
quarterback he played at wisconsin that
was ever any good well
uh oh scott tolzien come on come on
wow okay jim sorgy uh uh
so who's the other guy that's a coach
now
oh there's another guy's a coach that
will i oh
daryl bevel daryl bevel wasn't oh daryl
bevel yes once yeah
yeah yes yes yes in the 90s uh top 10
quarterbacks
in general should i just do the list off
the top of my head to don't worry
about it if you got the list go bad no
i'm going to make everyone really mad
because i'm going to forget someone
and they're going to be very very upset
all right off top my head this is better
than sims list
just guaranteed uh patrick mahomes one
uh aaron rodgers two tom brady three
josh allen four
justin fields five oh shut up
just [ __ ] now see just why not now
you're wasting our time
no i'm not okay no i'm not all right
keep going in the middle
like bortles six what no i'm no
blake baker mayfield six blake portal
seven
[Music]
russell wilson 10. all right good well
done
well done uh i i i knew that blake
bortles and jared goff once i heard
justin fields i knew that uh
the list was gonna go off the wheels all
right the real dr lou will the steelers
even come
close to their vegas win total of eight
and a half wins he really was a surprise
yesterday
to hear that they had released david de
castro there had been some rumbling
because he didn't participate in the
mandatory mini camp that something was
up
but that's just another piece gone from
that offensive line hey we're keeping
big ben we got najee harris
we got juju smith schuster back they
still need an offensive line or none of
it's gonna work
hold on mike though i i saw everyone
talking about this yesterday
it has to be one or the other here the
steelers had a terrible offensive line
last year
there they couldn't run the ball
whatsoever and then they
release or some guys retire or you know
they they turn over their offensive line
and everyone says
well how can you do that well which one
is it
but which one is it tell me which one it
is well
well it can be both it could be
we had not like hang on hang on we had a
crappy offensive line
and our four best offensive linemen are
gone
so it's gonna be even worse but they but
if they had a terrible offensive line
they must not have been that good
anymore
who but who have you ever pushed them
with next man up next do you understand
what you're saying
but do you understand what i'm saying
you can't have it both
ways here if the steelers had a terrible
offensive line last year
and it was legitimately drafted
offensive lineman in round one
draft an offensive alignment trade up
yeah i don't disagree with that but
but turning it over i don't know i want
to see it there's
odds are they're still going to have a
bad offensive line but you know what
they had last year
a bad offensive line so they're at least
trying to change it
trying to get better i don't know i
agree with you they should have drafted
in the first round absolutely
they also might just be like let's just
let big ben get killed
i don't know i i listen i
think that roethlisberger and the
steelers will by the middle of november
regret that he came back for another
year
they got themselves all juiced up on
this idea that and you know it was in
the aftermath of the season just far
enough removed from it hey we were 11-0
if we fix this fix this do this we'll be
fine
maybe they they fell into your line of
reasoning well you know our offensive
line wasn't very good so who cares if we
lose four of the starters
from our offensive line next man up
can't be much worse
let's go ahead and bring big ben back
let's let's load up the cannon one more
time
i i just i you know this is the tom
brady conversation
at a higher level ben roethlisberger i
think is in the process
of breaking down it was the elbow two
years ago
the knees last year were constantly an
issue even though he never appeared on
the injury report with a knee problem
there's a knee issue it may be there's
nothing to put on the
injury report because he doesn't have
any cartilage and it's arthritis
and what can you really do for it it's
not like you're in the treatment room
for it you just
try to deal with it i i just i i think
that it's it's not going to go well for
the steelers and this dicastro thing
makes me feel even more strongly about
it all right
uh let's see what else we have where do
you understand my please go ahead
you wanna i get your point okay but i
don't see who they're
they drafted a guy around two i just
don't see where they're gonna have
better offensive lineman this year
okay now let me let me add this point
though
um because i don't know that you and i
have discussed this there was an
excellent article at some point by
ed bushet of the athletic talking jerome
bettis about
commitment to the run and he thought the
steelers didn't have the commitment to
the run
and it's it's a mentality that is
instilled in training camps so
i think mike tomlin even though they're
not going back to st vincent college in
la trobe they announced that yesterday
but during training camp they're going
to split it between their facility and
heinz field
tomlin and the offensive coordinator and
the offensive line coach i think they
are going to do everything they can
to to make sure that they've got five
guys who are ready to go out there
and and and be as aggressive and as
dedicated and as driven
as possible to opening holes for naji
harris we'll see if it works
but uh you know and i wouldn't be
surprised to make a move or two we'll
see who's available
that they could bring in on the
offensive line but and they signed trey
turner yesterday by the way after
cutting david de castro i don't know
that's a huge difference but it just
shows that they know they need to do
something
bromani jones hey big cat how many wins
does famous jameis eat this year we
talked earlier about him being an off
the radar mvp candidate
what do you think the saints do with
jameis under center if he's the starter
he's gonna be the starter mike your your
little taysom hill project is
is ridiculous uh it's not my taste some
hill project it's sean payton's jason
hill project he's got a slightly more
important vote than i do
i'd have to look at their schedule but
i'm actually gonna throw it out there
i'm going to think that the
saints are going to go they're going to
win 11 games
how many seven games what 11 the
the over under is nine and a half matt
casey was telling me the over
under his nine and a half so i didn't
hear you say eleven so eleven and six
still gotta get used to that not easy to
do uh i actually think they can win more
than that
because their defense is still very good
they've got alvin kamara michael thomas
is gonna be healthy again this year
and and sean sean payton is the master
of drawing up all the way up until
kickoff new ideas
new looks new plays and you know big cat
in all seriousness one of the
factors that i think will decide who
stays as quarterback
which of the guys between taysom hill
and jameis winston is the most adept
at at processing a new stack of plays
that sean payton has written up on the
back of the napkin from breakfast as he
has yet another brainstorm because he
never stops thinking about new plays and
they install new plays all the time
a walk through on sunday morning of a
game they'll put in new plays
which of the two guys can process it and
execute it with limited advance
preparation or notice
that's going to be a big factor in who
keeps that job as the season unfolds
yeah agreed i i i looking at that
schedule just glancing at i
think that they have 11 wins there that
roster is good to go
like it is it would i've i was a big
time believer that drew brees
was holding them back the last couple of
years and that was a super bowl worthy
roster that had
a glaring hole at the quarterback
position when the playoff games get here
everything gets tighter you can't throw
deep you can't stretch the field
james swinson can do all that so i think
uh i think the saints are gonna have a
good year
at griff janssen's how many wins did the
lions get based on
the pure grit of dan campbell
that's a great question 22-1 to win the
division
uh that's a great question i i think
they get at least two
just on grit honestly
i don't know how many win the wins they
have overall but two of them where are
they beaten
there's the 17 games give me the wins
where are the wins all right
week one man all right so they're gonna
beat the packers come on
um they'll probably at green bay they're
gonna win ad grant come on come on
they'll beat the bengals uh
eagles they'll be yeah i
they might have three wins in here the
broncos maybe the car
like that one that stretch stretch at
the end of the season
six games they'll get one out of that
and they're gonna have
yeah four wins five one five wins i'm
gonna throw it out there five i think
five and twelve
five and twelve i agree with you and
here here's the reality
what the lions are doing with kind of
this old school
chris spielman dan campbell kneecap
biter vibe
it's so different than what other teams
currently do that if you have
guys who buy in if you have guys who
will go out there and be kind of rough
and tumble within the boundaries of the
rules
that does give you an edge because
that's something that teams aren't doing
now
so it's going gonna surprise him it's
gonna frustrate teams you know those
teams that are a little extra physical
that play through the whistle that will
do things that other teams won't do that
maybe put you at a greater physical risk
even though they're legal
i'm not advocating anything beyond what
the
law and the rules allow but if you have
a team that pushes it to the limit
a team can be a pain in the ass and you
don't want to deal with them and i feel
like that's what the lines are going to
be
i agree it's there is a certain window
here
that dan campbell will have guys playing
really really hard for him
and if he can get a couple wins that
they're not supposed to get
and guys believing that can become
something that's kind of
the path here for him and he's got jared
goff as his quarterback so i mean that's
that's that's worth five wins in and of
itself i don't like you ten and
seven you okay you take you would take
some hell over jared goff which is crazy
yes i would the guy who plays like five
gadget plays a game is your franchise
quarterback
az skull two can we get sims versus big
cat
at ruffin rowdy sims loses and he does
the show
five days a week i i wouldn't mess with
sims i wouldn't mess with you either
but i wouldn't mess with sims reach is
always the big advantage
listen i i played a game of wiffle ball
on wednesday and i am still so sore from
it my days are far
far over find that tweet someone find
that tweet because i we talked about
ben i am so sore i am
just dead i am i'm way over the hill
there's
it's over for me so there's nothing that
could get me to fighting rough and rowdy
and i like sims even though nbc keeps
offering me his job
i do genuinely like sims
i i uh i saw some photos from whatever
it was you guys were doing on wednesday
and uh relax relax
it was it was disturbing there's not
much avocado ice cream being served at
whatever you guys were doing i'll just
say that
relax you're not you don't look so great
either
okay i don't run around with my shirt
off
i don't run around my shirt off and have
it photographed and put on social media
i admire
i admire the willingness news flash mike
you know what here take this new
take this breaking news and and hope
that no other
nfl insider steals it from you i'm fat
okay
there's the breaking news
as you get closer to 40 there are health
reasons at play i'm just trying to make
you you know you got you got some young
children you got to be around for them
all right i appreciate that and tomorrow
morning and tomorrow morning you will
inspire millions to go out and buy
donuts
as we await once a week morning donut
tweet i'm telling you i
i it has inspired me to buy and eat
donuts because those things that you buy
wherever you get them they look damn
good the next time in new york i got to
go to that bakery okay
yes uh at low tea contessa
why don't big cat and florio get
matching tats like
chris sims and shanahan they are way
closer and
and just doesn't know the story kyle
shanahan
and chris sims were teammates at the
university of texas they have each
other's initials tattooed on their legs
apparently they aren't the only ones
there were multiple teammates who who
did so there's this
list of letters like some weird da vinci
code on chris sims leg of letters so
if i'm going to get a tattoo i'm not
getting letters i'm getting something
more interesting than
than letters or initials i'm going all
do you think chris looks at his tat
now and he just sees mac jones
uh uh or or trey lance one of the two
or just or it just says or it just says
kyle lied to me
you should get it it just drops like
harry potter's it throbs like harry
potter's uh
scar on his forehead he sees the ks and
it's just like it's like infected now 20
years after
he did the actual tattoo i never read
that i
i don't have a tattoo but i tell
as i get older i have this weird urge to
go get
one me too i don't know what it would be
but i want to get one
me too i i've talked about this
extensively i don't think that you can
just be
36 years old and become tattoo guy but i
want to be
i don't know how i do it because you
have to do it you can't just like start
getting a ton right away
you have to ease your way into it how do
you do it where it's not
like super you know in your face i also
i think we can both agree i'm probably
never gonna have a real job my entire
life for the rest of my life
hopefully knock on wood so i can get a
tattoo maybe a neck tattoo
maybe a face tattoo and probably still
do my job
um yeah i i uh look i
i've got 20 years on you and i think
about it so i don't think it's
unreasonable to think about it not that
i would get a neck tack two
or a face tattoo and i know you're not
serious about it but hey if you choose
to do it go for it
i think we just talked ourselves into
doing this getting matching tats
let's do it um we gotta let's just go
let's just do it let's be wild and crazy
mike
it's the last day before vacation last
day of school
all right uh next question which one
here we go
at a rhodes 27 big cat first time long
time when you buy your donuts on
saturday mornings do you plan it out
ahead of time
or you just get caught up in the moment
and improvise no so the place i go to
in brooklyn um it's got it
it has a limited selection so everyone
always criticizes like oh how did you
not get jelly how did you
they don't have they make whatever they
make it's a place where it opens
at 9 00 a.m and they just sell donuts
until it's cl until they run out
and that's how you know a place is great
so like it's usually out at noon
but uh i do not i sort of improvise but
there's not a lot to work with
they're the best donuts i've ever had in
my life i enjoy my saturday morning
i go with my son we have a little moment
it's great it's a little tradition
so everyone who hates on it take a hike
okay
i don't want i don't want any negative
vibes on saturday mornings
you had one recently that
it looked like it had and and and i i'm
catholic my whole life i was an older
boy
the priest always had the big giant
communion wafer
it looked like half of the big giant
communion wafer
on top of the icing you know what i'm
talking about yes yes
i think that was a cookies and cream one
so yeah they i mean
they're they're incredible and i again i
look forward to it it's a nice little
thing that i do with my son
um it's just fun to be able to wake up
and be like hey let's get in the car
grab some coffee
grab some donuts bring it back for the
family
guess what i like it news flash you got
your two-year-old son helped up on
caffeine
it's a little early yeah he has the car
he actually makes the coffee for me
all right let's let's say i've i've
noticed that you have become
in recent weeks quite the coffee
aficionado as well that's that's
actually longer than weeks
i just love just the memes because
people are like you're so lame
you're so over the hill it's like yeah i
know i literally google
lame coffee memes and then post it on
twitter when i'm tired
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports